the game is thousand to one
you decide who leaves with a thousand
dollars round one begins
i think we should describe everyone's
situation for us very briefly because we
can't have one we could do it that way
or we could do like we have competitions
like i feel like competitions isn't the
best
i just don't want anybody to leave with
their feelings hurt or feeling like my
problems aren't big enough and i feel
ashamed for talking welcome to life
honey
feelings are going to get hurt people
are going to leave without cash
life what i would do to 1 000 is help
start
uh online clothing business i want the
one thousand dollars
from education i'm a senior right now
and just want to
put the money towards college actually i
i'm taking like a couple classes
so most of my money would go to like
paying my car insurance and my like
school fees
and then on top of that i got invited to
a wedding in florida whatever i had left
over i'd try to get a good plane ticket
over there
so i could be at the wedding i'd be a
marine biologist when i grow up
i love the ocean i love animals it's
just where i get my happiness from
really
there's this trip to the bahamas which
is very very expensive and a thousand
dollars would help me go to that
what
[Music]
what very genuine
you want to pay for your school i want
to go to the bahamas it's very expensive
you want to pay for your beat up car um
i want to go to the bombs
you want to better your education
[Music]
in my current home i'm pretty much left
to fund myself basically
it really sucks because the school that
i go to um they don't
supply buses to my house area so i have
to take uber's like everywhere and it's
like
that's expensive yes it's like a lot of
stress on me
and it's like i'm sorry i'm getting
emotional
well that is my i really want to go to
the bahamas
you may just say hey you take a lot of
ubers
could you take an uber to bahamas
wow we get really expensive not as much
as a trip to obama this is something the
bahamas
the obama so obama's but ain't obama's
in the bahamas
it's like i'm being forced to grow up so
fast and i'm only 16.
nina were you the one that said we
shouldn't do what we just did
yes i don't know i think it can make
people feel like their reasons aren't
good enough or automatically make people
feel like well
we should give her the money or give him
the money for this reason or that reason
and not to say that that isn't valid but
everybody else is also valid and so i
think if we decided through like a
random competition
that's a way that nobody could feel it
she looks like that gif where the guy's
just seeing numbers all over isaac
newton type [ __ ] she's just no she just
figured out she's [ __ ] she's [ __ ] up
no you know what she shouldn't say
because she was one that was arguing
against nina earlier
it's like no we should just say why we
need it but she's the one out of all of
them who seems to needed the list so
she's just realizing that i just did
i just myself congratulations
you played yourself i feel the opposite
personally because i feel like
we should give it to the person who
needs it and who deserves it and another
one you just played yourself
again i feel comfortable talking about
the stuff i have going on at home
that would make a difference like one
vote for me
sorry college no it's three to two i'm
sorry i feel like we should do something
fun you know something to bring up the
mood maybe who can stay on level there's
one foot the longest 20.
should we do that one leg is standing up
the first one falling out sure
three two one foot up
[Music]
couch
i'm buddhist everybody so i know it's
like 10 times a day
i'm out are you out
how do you feel do you think that was
fair during the no
did you say no no it's not fair but
you're the one that suggested it is she
the one that said that
ain't she the one that suggested it why
are you salty
just because you can't go to the bahamas
i don't think anybody had like an upper
hand
i'm
so we're not going to listen to the
couch right guys who's the leader here
nina i feel like it's the three of us
nina you're not gonna lie
whoa okay nina
but i feel like she's got a problem with
her leading the conversation
we agree yeah i just don't know where
that came from does she have like a
happy place
that's a lot bro she gotta be with her
you keep influencing everyone
how am i influencing i think i think
she's just trying to make everything
work is it cool if we stop getting input
from the couch for a little bit because
this is between
inclusion us five do people agree that's
a fair figure i agree
yeah this is awkward she went from
bahamas to biomass
so what went from bahamas to buy nina
oh my god these shut you out it feels
extra weird to do commentary on this
because they're teenagers
yeah it's really weird because she was a
grown woman i was like girl put your
tears away but
it's a kid it's a kid it's a kid it's
normal that you cry and that's why you
learn stuff that's what you learn about
all this stuff
yeah it doesn't mean that she's going to
be like that or she's going to be some
kind of way yeah
the rest of her life yeah that's not the
best reason to cry right now i'm gonna
just shut my mouth
yeah you should what was your reasoning
again
nj um pay for my ib testing aj what
about you
but that's the thing like i that wasn't
my reason my reason was
school fees it's a lot deeper than what
i said but i don't want to get into it
because it's like that
isn't it crazy that these teenagers seem
more private and more about like
keeping information then the grown-ups
did the grown-ups were desperate
yo it was really gross watching the
growing at least with this group
i actually like the idea of just playing
randomly that's cringy yeah because
in this group it's like who's willing to
bear their heart out the most
necessarily who necessarily deserves it
because deserves is relative and it's
subjective you don't actually have all
the information about each individual
they might be hiding stuff
that they don't want to mention to other
people so even bahama girl the way
everybody handles it is better
than whatever how the adults ended yeah
i loved it the way she went nina nina
and that was better than you know here's
the thing right when you're within a
group of people
some people don't like the idea they
don't like the specific leader chosen
or they don't like the idea that someone
else is leading the thing and to me it's
like it's okay if someone takes the lead
someone has to yeah it doesn't mean that
person is like a control freak it's like
there's a situation it's a little bit
chaotic everyone's uncomfortable someone
has to start speaking up
it doesn't mean that person has a
massive ego or that you have to fight
them on stuff
just my opinion know many times i've sat
in a group and someone just starts
speaking up and they handle stuff i'm
like sure
right yeah but that's not everybody that
takes it like that they take really
there's a lot
looking by these people to take a lot of
offense it's just you talking
yeah you in a conversation you're able
to talk and everything
and people just take that in the fence
when you're able to shut them down
just because they don't have the
arguments and you're like well that
argument is not necessarily right
because the facts are really this and
that and that
and they don't have no more arguments
they resort to oh yeah so you know
everything right
mr and noah like no it's not even like
that nobody since the beginning of
the discussion you've been like no no
i'm just i'm just talking like
everybody's talking
if you take your space you take your
space that if you don't
i'm not responsible if you don't want to
take your space and stuff
but people really take it personal when
you're going to be the one talking in a
group or you weren't going to bring
facts i feel like oftentimes people
don't want to deal with their own
inadequacies and efficiencies
so they rather say you're a control
freak rather than admitting to
themselves that they didn't seize the
moment
or that they do not have what it takes
to do it you know it's kind of like when
we're in haiti right they were supposed
to take care of us but we took care of
them
and at one point it was you [ __ ] it was
you in the front i was just chill in the
back yeah it was me
you think i was there like uh you're in
control it's like yo sometimes you gotta
just learn to take a back seat
it's okay how many times have we done
shows
right and it'll be a back and forth and
then sometimes you'll just jump in the
front you'll do your thing
i sit back and i watch yeah and it's
okay you don't have to
have this giant ego where you or or feel
like because
because you have your own insecurities
it's because of the person in front of
you it's okay to just live with those
insecurities
that's it that's that's what i'm feeling
right now yeah yeah it is you know how
many times i watch you like do a big ass
speech and then everyone goes off and
i'm saying they're like yeah [ __ ] get
it
it's a chin ah it happens most of the
time
what am i lying i'm not gonna
go into it i'm gonna just let this one
go i'm gonna sit in the back
if he wants to shine let him shine i'm
sorry can we really pause
i really don't need you to antagonize me
why don't you just be quiet
i have been okay then keep going back to
that yeah you want to do something
physical something like a quiz that quiz
sounds pretty
yeah we can do like a quiz on you on
ocean facts
ocean fast okay yeah no she's not
handling they well she is not she's
seeking for revenge maybe
i'll take what i said back ej oh man
all right you're really nice i really
like you
dj come join us
think of something fun creative outside
of the box that we can use how about the
drawing contest
all right let's have a drawing contest
then sure and then are we voting or
who's voting
let's have the couch no because they
have their preferences no but you
shuffled it so we don't know whose it is
you guys want to play like rock paper
scissors together
i'm chilling
oh wow
i'm not gonna lie to you bro ain't mad
at you i'm not even the lady bro i'm
starting to feel bad
i ain't mad at him i almost feel like
some of these videos like this shouldn't
even be allowed
oh i imagine if you imagine whatever
insecurities that she's got she got
problems or whatever
yeah you know she watches the reactions
to these videos or the video
yeah and everyone clowning her but is
she gonna feel worse
yeah and for someone in that kind of a
fragile state who's
a teenager somebody makes me feel
uncomfortable yeah but then again you
know
it was funny though
but this is the new age of the internet
that's why i'm saying for me as a kid if
i got clowned at school it's fine
but i don't have to constantly relive
that or watch that moment all the time
when i was a kid
that's why i feel bad for her yeah once
i got home it stopped the bullying
stopped when once i got home dude yeah
like do you think kids should be able to
consent to something like this you know
since we're on this i don't think [ __ ] i
don't right i don't think that the kids
did
i i think that the parents did i don't
think that they're allowed to even
ask the kids to be like that on on that
they have to ask the kids i don't think
a parent should be able to choose for
their kid whether or not they can handle
something like this either
just me personally who then i don't
think they because here's the thing
you think you just shouldn't be there
period because what attitude does the
parent have for knowing whether or not
their kid can handle this kind of online
retaliation their parents didn't grow up
in that generation true
so they don't know true yeah if you're
not in the business it's not because
you're a parent that you actually know
what's best if
when it comes to this it's like not in
the business you don't know if your
parent
your parents your parents they love you
great they don't know what it's like to
be a soldier and to go to war
so they can make the decision for you
yeah doesn't mean they know what they
talk about
right so i agree that's just my thoughts
that's what you're saying this is going
to be the best damn
octopus i've ever drawn so how's your
girlfriend
oh come on
every time i'm about to burst out
laughing i remind myself as a kid so the
one that we
picked i already see it we're the loser
is the scary one
okay i'm out it's really funny how now
she's influencing the vote
and it's okay did you want me out did
you want me out no
actually like most of the people that i
won in the final three are there
but just like not all of them what'd you
say i said most of the people
on the couch right now are what i wanted
on the final three oh oh
thank you most nina nina
nina not you oh
no no no actually you didn't hear that
part the producer went most
most was drama he just dropped that
right there one of you my favorite
listen
the one that did the editing did her
dirty no
no no no she did her dirty or maybe she
maybe they cut out even more than
no she did her girl yeah all right what
are you gonna say
i feel like we should for this last run
we should like you know obviously state
our
opinions do you guys want our opinions
or no no
this is as long as we don't like know
that they're singing one of us out or
something then i think that's fair
okay yeah we'll hear it sure i'd say
heather
i don't know you just like have an
impact on me
yeah what do you think ej um i would say
heather too
don't take it as like pity like they're
pitying me is like if you need it you
need it like
i would also say heather i honestly
think that she needs it earlier i said
heather
so i'm gonna keep that decision
so the girl in the middle got it um
honestly it's just it's crazy to me that
kids have
like behaved themselves much better than
adults like how shameless the grown-ups
were compared to them
was really really surprising as far as
the young girl i'm not going to do some
kind of analysis all that stuff
she's a teenager you know people got
you got time to develop you got to give
people chances so
um you know hopefully hopefully she
learns some things and hopefully the
internet's not too hard on her but
that's too much to ask i'm sure
i think it was just crazy to see the
contrast between the last video was like
your opinion is invalid and this one
they were like consulting each other and
still being open they even consulted the
people on the on the bench
on the bench on the couch which the
adults are like now you out
now you out i approve of this i approve
this as a whole i'm with it
but not the fate of their kids it's just
it's a weird it's a weird territory it
is
it's a really weird territory because i
don't think we've done enough research
into finding out how these kinds of
things affect kids long term
i know how it affects adults when they
go on to these shows
or do these videos so i'm gonna have to
take off all their profiles they have to
isolate themselves from the internet for
a while
take the errand girl who had to remove
all their presents online for a while
right to this day this still gets
harassed now
imagine she was 16.
you did what i'm saying so that's that's
the worry i have for this yeah like i
said when i got to go home the bullying
stopped
uh tell us what you guys think in the
comments below
[Music]
foreign